[音楽]
うううう
こんにちは集めしそうです
macbook
5000万円部です
あれ
いつのことだったでしょうか
かれこれ
1年前になると思います
[音楽]
一人の男
光るという男が
1億円のつかみ取りで
5,000万円
彼が
5000万円
とったことからこの図形ま
起きてしまいました今日は本人に来て
いただいておりますどうぞ
ドン1年前に5000万円を獲得した1番
の日からです武蔵日です私ですあれて
欲しいでしょ前田
ございま
どういたしました話せ御説明させて
いただきますと聞かれさん誕生日だったん
ですよでを鍛造日に触れてばあげたいなと
思ってこれをちょっとまた送ってしまった
んですけども助言と使う術させてあげたい
なと思ってピカラ三者委長兼つか見て
どうぞ
やらせてみたら
5000万円トップしまったと
一駅です
いやいやいいんですよかなさんも好きな時
撮ってもらって youtube 一番
イケてなかったりもしました
人生で初めてやり直したいと思いました一
日を公開した
イジェもういいなって思いますが気版回り
方が者全員が生まれは公開しましたでも
惹かれさんに5000万円福徳されてどう
しようかという話をしてずーっとしてくる
だけがまあいろんな上がってたんですよ光
さんは結構もうなんでもええでーと言って
くださって俺とかじゃないかこれやって俺
がもらった程度もなんかこうもライン
にくいし5千万もらう人の気持ちって結構
しんどい
からあの桜咲けご送金で4000なんぼ
一体何すごいた末こそあれすごいっすよね
すごい
俺きつい午前は行ったりファンってこられ
たらちょっと打ってなるなんかこうそれを
平気で飛行使うみたいな感じにならなかっ
たちょっと使いづらかったみたいなず返せ
なかったですチルクを壊すこともできたん
ですけど
ちょっとそういう気分にならなかったんだ
ええもう別はじめ所が好きないって使って
いいよっていう風に言ってあげてますそう
いろは事務所考えて言って結構な
めちゃくちゃうまくいったんでまとまら
なくて結果も家で勃っちゃうそうですね
いろいろさんとのやりとり結構させて
いただいてどうしようかと李光さん的には
やっぱ視聴者さんとか盛り上げた方がまあ
ね財貨という話を聞いて僕も純正に何か
面白いことできねえかなあとキュッとさ
せるところ
プレゼント9ばいいんじゃないかと夏休み
やし夏休みですね国大の音超特大これから
5000万円やっぱりハワイ州一からさん
結構されている水あるって事は俺は結構
やったらこれ神社ですかプレゼント企画の
僕ですほぼないんですよ確かやったりし
ないのかな
俺はれや積んで人に物をあげたくないん
ですよまあ嫌じゃないですよ取って動画
撮りたいなんて大タイプなんで今回光る様
のお陰で5000枚て買う決心がつきまし
たけどねああやってますけどよかった皆様
これ光るサウンドがいいです皆さん
[音楽]
いやまぁもうね正直ねあの僕は何使っても
よかったんです5000万円この
5000万の地盤がのがるっズッパその
気持ちでいっぱいで正直何から3日にあの
はじめ所号線はどうなったそれが煩わしく
てはずらしくて乗っています俺もうハム5
千万受けてるのもしんどいし使うの捕手の
ができていたがもう一台だったから期待値
上がる人っていいと思いますどうしよう道
バネ竿にと思う落ちれなのかなとという
わけでまずブレゼント何かと言いますと
はいいろいろを新しいことはなく増税に
macbook pro でございます
もちろん新品ね新品ですタイプ3回来る
しっかりあっでこれでねーなんか特別仕様
というか一般の市場に行って回っていない
カスタマイズモデルになりますこれそれ
すごいよやっぱだからこそこの買い占め
みたいなにはならないですよなのです一般
に出回ってないからこそを買い占めで
なんかも独占したみたいな感じにはならな
いってそこはへ
場に出しましたはいこれを買いたいと思っ
てで買えるやつはないので改善にはなって
ないでご安心くださいそこはそこで時間方
のちょっとあります
まあこれ300台をしましたなんで
パソコンで知ったかと言いますとスマホと
かで撮影と編集の画面ができるんですけど
せ守って誰もが結構持っているまあみんな
が持って行っとらんだよパソコンって
やっぱりこう買おうと思わないとかいない
と思うんですよ動画編集とかも鉄のそう
ですしいろんな仕事とかここで使ってい
ますプレサージュで勉強からこりゃもう誰
がもらっても嬉しいのかなということで
遊んと厳正な審査で抽選は寿司ますので
そこ完成してください千和さんの僕は一切
何も出来ません確かねはじめ生姜で言って
何から今日可愛い子ばっか買っちゃうねっ
そうなしてそれ本当に真逆だからお金持ち
でも当たっちゃうあたります関係なくそー
なんかそれがしたかったという2回 ad
を言えない人でも気に入る可能性50全員
here アプリの登録ところそうですね
パターン5000まほっ
ああ僕とメリットというかそのプラス
アルファのところ部分がこれは well
ぐらいに無理だったんで本当に創星の子
専門が消えるっていうそういう曲ですか
けどそこに届け作ったなら光る様が
5000万円取ったをかけたので
ありがとうございまーねアトッチ貼ってね
あれは丸山を2分俺じゃなかったらなと
いうわけで今回のプレゼント企画のものは
macbookを5000万円分300台
となっておりますを配布俺はすごいなんと
なくていいんで応募したら当たり可能性も
あるので皆さん是非応募すれば妻も軽い
気持ちでねっなんかまぁ
動作たらいいの僕やっとこフライト気持ち
で応答できるっていう方が情報でじっと
登録を入れません至ってシンプルに憤慨が
せていただきますと夕食応募御説明にいき
ますまずはもうほんと光さんと僕から
これだけです
はず3冊をあの光る両方の公式
twitter をフォローしてください
はい同じ1ですますそして外れその
アカウントよりキャンペーン用のツイート
だしますそのツイートをリツイートして
くださいこれがないですまだこのリ
ツイートと+フォローをさえすれば応募
完了といっていつ何時でも ok ですし
引用リツイーとでも ok ですそして
ゴールを外してしまうと抽選対象から外れ
てしまいますのでご注意くださいこれは
是非お疲れ様僕の字とも終わってからも
通してくれるとお得な情報が手に入ります
そしてへ非公開アカウント鍵垢ですね鍵垢
は抽選対象外となる可能性があるので必ず
公開アカウントで参加をお願いします
そして応募期間がですね今日7号2-22
日から1月度28日の木曜日約1週間
くらいはい1週間ないくらいの23時59
分59秒までとさせていただきます
twitter 持って中はカードを作っ
てそれ位置するだけだってめちゃ簡単です
これはそして統制された方のみに教え
twitter カウントから dm にて
お知らせしますのでもうそれもあるので
フォローしていただきたいというところも
あります当選しましたってお知らせは
2022年の8月中に送らせて頂きますの
ではいですお待ち下さいお願いします
ちょっといろいろ多分応募とかの抽選と
なるのでいつ当選するかはなかなか
はっきり言えないんで
一応8月中とさせていただきますそして
中世ファンランダムで不完全なのは完全な
のにそれズレしたら僕坊主にしますズーム
しようもないしたこれはい光る様坊主にし
ますかもう全然もちろん俺が入らんだって
可愛い仰いだから
申します
皆さんの僕が選んだらかわいい今年はいか
ないので
もちろんコスプレアドに2人ガストジャン
グラビアアイドルでしかもいますちゃんと
システムを使うので病棟になっております
どうぞご安心ください当選発表の際に
なりすますあかーんとに2してください光
さんはじめしゃちょーたくさんアカウント
でてくるかもしれませんはぁいらっしゃい
ますね公式マークついているちゃんとこの
峰2-2twitter から dm だけ
です概要欄にちゃんと twitter
ありますのでてくださいはじめシャツを
しっかりそこは間違いないようにお願いし
ますはいこれ大事です本当に変な詐欺とか
同い年の出入りしますお願いしまーすたー
ず3冊を欲しい光さんへ直接 dm など
で問い合わせしても返信は出来ませんので
そこかご了承ください逆に光さんと僕から
うとなんか変なことになっちゃうのでへ
行っに黒子関与しないで別のところで
しっかりやってもらいますので僕らのでは
一切問い合わせないようにお願いしますお
願いしますそういうわけでもう本日から
始まっているわけなんですけどもどこまで
これか下されれば損とに想像つかないです
ねこれを5000万分のプレゼント結構
やばいねやっぱりすればですなんかこれを
23回とかどうかだけど300台って言う
ヤバされ俺も視聴者と同じ行くバック
モニターガーラ事務所謎のある
総応募と例えば僕も光さんのこれで
巻き込まれたみたところなのでパパお互い
などこんな座のまあまあ麻生は捕まえ
へんかったらそうじゃなかっ明るさが使っ
てくれたからこそこうやって今は僕の
5000万円が皆さんの希望という意味に
パーって良かった
ティムロスするん twitter走った
ことかでずっと年間パワーもしれない話
ですよそれか決めた頃まで5戦も終わった
便で5000万渡部と思います光社長の
5000万円ページェントどうか発車多分
それ以降それでいきましょうそれちょっと
いっしょツイートにも載ってると思うん
ですけども eu リツイートとかさんで
さえもぜひそれはしたくっつけてダサい中
ラガーさんお会いします頭保存についてで
盛り上げてくれと嬉しい分3つ嬉しいです
それくださいそういうわけでサブ
ユーチューバーそしてなんかこの個人な
感じで千万でもう何も利益もを止めない数
やするの
今後はないと思うので
ないですぜひこの図 macbook 手
に入れてみてはいかがでしょうかお待ち
参加してください見て下さん
ちょい5000万円つかんでくれて
ありがとうございましたでありました
[音楽]